today's one minute monday is be better I
get a lot of entrepreneurs who write in
Tamina say everyone i wish i had my
momentum i wish i had more customers
which i had more money coming in that
only happens when you get better at what
you do I look at my youtube channel and
you know we're coming up on two million
views I wish I was that 200 million
views I can get there by being better
and if you look at my channel you look
at where it was two years ago go look at
some of the older videos the videos now
are way better than they were two years
ago and that's why the views may be 3 5
10 20 times as much but I still need to
get better and so do you if you're not
getting the results that you want from
your business then you need to be better
I want you to think about three things
in the customer experience from the
product or bind to the service they're
getting to every single interaction they
get with you think of three things that
you can make better because you want
every single time a customer comes and
talks to you you want them leaving
saying wow that was amazing if you're
not there yet then you need to be better
believe